the bells already been wrong
and they've heard it
but in the dark among the stars
no the goddess dead
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie big
surprise Zack Snyder dropped a new
teaser trailer for the Justice League
Snyder cut so we'll break it down
there's a whole bunch of Mythology that
they're teasing here so it's actually
pretty cool if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos will do a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave all your theories about the
Snyder cut on the video most important
stuff first if you didn't know Zack
Snyder will be doing a special Justice
League Snyder cut panel at the big fan
dome event that's happening later this
year that sort of DC's own separate
comic-con does - doing by themselves
it's gonna be totally free it'll be
online so everybody will be able to
participate in some way but the really
cool thing about this footage is that it
gives us a first look at Darkseid in the
new cut of the movie and he's very
different in the version of the
flashback scene that Wonder Woman has if
you can't tell what's being said during
this scene either it's Lex Luthor's
voice whispering to her a disembodied
voice while she's staring at darkseid's
picture he says the Bell has been rung
and they've heard it they know that god
is dead so obviously the god that
they're talking about is Superman they'd
found out about his death during Batman
be a Superman when he says they he's
talking about Darkseid in the forces of
apocalypse in the way that Lex Luthor
references Superman as God makes it
sound like Superman was the reason
Darkseid had not come for the mother
boxes sooner there was some footage from
the theatrical cut where Steppenwolf
voice-over says no protectors no
Kryptonians no lanterns this world will
fall as if there were Kryptonians before
Superman I know there are a lot of
theories about who that other Kryptonian
was from the Man of Steel movie in the
Kryptonian pod that had been opened Zack
Snyder always hinted that they would
reveal that in future sequels but we
never really found out for sure there
were a lot of theories that that could
be their version of Supergirl that would
show up at some point or it could be
just another ancient Kryptonian when
their race used to be explorers as he
gets that big backstory during the Man
of Steel movie I don't know if that
implies that we'll actually see some
Kryptonian added into this flashback
Darkseid war scene though but as for the
Green Lantern Corps the Green Lantern's
we know who this Green Lantern was in
the flashback scenes and what was going
on with him and we know what was going
on in present day with Green Lantern
Corps I'll talk about them in a second
but the place where Wonder Woman is
looks like it's either
miss Kiran temple or an ancient Greek
temple built by humans because the
language that she's reading here on it
is written in ancient Greek it would be
from before she was born though
otherwise she wouldn't be so surprised
to see Darkseid's image in the text
identifying him
I don't read Greek so I can't tell you
what the text on the left says someone
who reads Greek can probably just add
that in in the comments please but you
don't need to be able to read Greek to
identify what the text on the right says
it says Darkseid in ancient Greek the
object in the center of the mural
beneath him is what the three mother
boxes look like when they're combined
the whole thing with the mother boxes in
Zack Snyder's original version the movie
when they were still doing multiple
Justice League movies is that before
Darkseid became Darkseid his name was
ooks us but Darkseid was born the son of
yuga khan and hey grrah the king and
queen of apocalypse he was the second in
line for the throne behind his older
brother he killed him to obtain the
Omega force which is where his Omega
beams come from as the name implies it
also turned him into this rock like
looking creature that you know as
modern-day Darkseid
he took the Darkseid name then in the
Snyder cut version in that backstory he
traps the soul of his mother in her
cosmic power Hydra in what they're
calling the unity the unity of these
three mother boxes then uses that cosmic
power to proceed to try and take over
the rest of the universe
so when they talk about the unity during
the movie that's what he's talking about
Steppenwolf was still in the Snyder cut
he still comes to earth but the reason
why he came to earth for the mother
boxes originally is because the soul of
his mother also Hegira which is
Darkseid's mother to is trapped inside
the mother boxes that's why Steppenwolf
keeps referring to the mother boxes like
they're alive calling them mother
talking about setting her free they
didn't really clarify that in the
theatrical cut so it just seems kind of
creepy that he's talking to the mother
boxes like they're a person he wants to
free her and use her celestial power to
defeat Darkseid himself and claim the
throne of apocalypse it's sort of
implied at the end of the movie that
they have some sort of loose alliance
and he's being taken back to apocalypse
through the boom tube the ending of the
Snyder cut was a little bit different
than the theatrical cut there were a lot
of big changes but part of the ending of
the movie was him being taken back to
Darkseid to be killed by Darkseid and
dark side
sort of give a stare to the Justice
League and let him know that he was
coming for them the scene of Lex Luthor
in the Kryptonian ship is also Adam
material from Batman V Superman when
he's learning all this about Darkseid
Steppenwolf the mother boxes the secret
history of Earth from the Kryptonian AI
this is what Steppenwolf looked like in
the Schneider cut he was way more
monstrous looking that's all supposed to
be happening right at the beginning of
the Justice League movie the Task Force
shows up arrest sim throws him in prison
and he spends pretty much all the first
Justice League movie in that prison cell
where you see Batman come to intimidate
him at the end of Batman vs Superman
but given this voiceover scene it also
sounds like the Lex Luthor story during
the Snyder cut is very different he
really only shows up in the post-credits
scene in the theatrical version but the
voice-over makes it sound like it's
happening pretty early in the movie so
it sounds like someone goes to see him
and ask some questions about what was
going on inside the Kryptonian ship
because he knows all this stuff now the
reason why Wonder Woman doesn't know all
this history yet is because she wasn't
born when this Dark Side war was
happening but then you have all these
scenes with Wonder Woman inspecting the
ruins with the Darkseid mural depicting
the flashback scene then either she
tells Batman this full story so that he
knows what's going on or they do the
full flashback war scene here while
she's staring at this mural the way they
cut the teaser trailer implies that the
flashback scene happens while she's
staring at darkseid's picture but that
might just be the way they cut the
trailer and not the way it actually
happens during the movie for the most
part the only major difference I think
in the actual flashback scene with
Darkseid fighting everyone is one that
Darkseid looks like this he doesn't seem
like he's fully become Darkseid yet he
doesn't seem like he has the Omega force
either because that would be enough to
kill every last one of the Greek gods
like Zeus Ares Hera Artemis all the
Greek gods are in the theatrical cut of
the flashback scene so I'm assuming it's
mostly the same for them in the
Schneider cut the other big Lex Luthor
changed we just found out about in the
Schneider cut is actually the
Deathstroke post-credit scene Joe
Manganiello tweeted out that they would
be adding the original post-credit scene
back in like he was really hyped up as
if it was way way better than the
theatrical cut my assumption without
seeing more footage is just that there's
a lot more nuance to this in the
Schneider cut like they say that they're
forming the injustice Society but the
scene is longer more fleshed out with
more con
texts and plot laying out how their
story will continue in future Justice
League sequels when they were still
gonna do multiple Justice League movies
I also think had the original plans for
the DC EU movies played out the way that
they wanted to this injustice league
post-credit scene would have also been
intended to set up a spin-off villain
team-up movie for the injustice society
maybe they would have called that movie
injustice and it would have just been
another Justice League sequel down the
line like Justice League 3 or 4 or
whatever it would have just been the
biggest DC villains and Lex Luthor
teaming up against the Justice League
which by that time would have included
Hal Jordan in the Green Lantern Corps
they would have also shown up by that
second Justice League movie fully and
there was supposed to be some
present-day Hal Jordan Green Lantern
stuff happening in the Snyder cut too so
hopefully they'll find a way to add him
back in I don't know if they cast an
actor it's hard to say because of so
many changes that they made if you
remember the deleted scene of Superman
showing up to talk to Alfred inside the
Batcave oh you're just in time that was
originally supposed to be a Green
Lantern Hal Jordan scene with him
showing up that's why in all the
trailers when they showed this scene you
see a flash of green in his eyes it's
supposed to be green lantern shining
showing up the whole idea with the Green
Lantern Corps in the Justice League
movies - starting with the flashback
scene if you don't know who this one is
in all the Darkseid war scenes this is
younger he's actually one of the ancient
Green Lantern's of space Sector two
eight one four where earth is located he
was a Green Lantern about 2,000 years
ago
eventually he wound up dying and his
body his force became part of the star
heart which then went on to power the
Alan Scott Green Lantern so they kind of
do a version of setting up an Alan Scott
Green Lantern maybe at some point in the
DC EU they had plan to do it justice
Society movie so just a reminder that
the DC fan dome event is happening at
the end of August they're gonna be
dropping trailers for a lot of the
upcoming movies and at least some
concept teasers and art for the upcoming
movies that they have not started
filming yet the rock also separately
dropped a comic-con teaser for the Black
Adam panel and Shazam to stuff that
they're doing at this big event so my
video for that should post in the next
day or so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that video when I post it and I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post that video
while you wait for everything click here
for my other just
sleek Snider cut teaser video and click
here for my brand-new Black Adam movie
video thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]